Hello everybody!
Hello, we're gonna start off by, whoa, Batman.
Okay, this like pan up all the way.
Yeah, let's just end it off on his pecs, I guess.
Damn, no face.
We're not here to look at Batman's fucking face.
We know his real assets right there.
Wow, Batman!
Damn!
Oh my god.
Well, hello, everybody.
Yeah, surprise!
A Batman stream!
I just, you know, his eyes are...
Yeah, his eyes are up here.
Yes!
If the game knows where it's supposed to end, Then, all I'm
trying to do is, like, you know, I'm trying to, whoa, see,
look at that.
Why is it never showing me his face?
But, yeah, anyway, as I was saying, surprise stream, I
really wanted to play Batman.
Yeah, like, I just, I just really wanted to play Batman.
We weren't able to earlier, so I was like, ah, I don't want
to be like, you know, The only gaming streams we had was
literally Apex.
I was like, I don't really want to have, like, back-to-back
Apex.
So, um, surprise, double stream.
We're going to start off with Batman.
And then later on, transition over to Apex.
Because I just thought it was, I don't know.
I thought it was a little weird to have, like, back-to-back
Apex.
I know you're like, but Doki, it's all, you're all about
Guys, it's not just, I'm more, I'm more than just Apex.
Oh my God, Sam, thank you for the 50 Gifted Chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, just like Batman, I'm more than just the Pax.
Just like Batman, there's more to me.
than just pecs guys there's more than me than just apex
there's more and that is why we're playing batman i'm a
variety streamer exactly anyway i've never played um i've
never played batman before um i've never played that like
okay i'm okay i've never played this type of batman game
before I've actually, I remember the, I remember, uh, my dad
playing, um, the Batman Arkham Asylum, like the Batman
series from the Arkham Asylum series.
Um, a long time ago.
Did you guys know this game is 10 years old?
Yes, I, I know a lot of dragoons are going to be incredibly
old.
Feel very old right now.
But this game is like more than 14 years old now.
it is almost 14 years oh no it's not even almost it is 14
years old now and um but yes I remember 14 years ago I
watched my dad play this game um and I don't really remember
much I know it's like voiced by Mark Hamill and Kevin Conroy
um who are like sort of like the OG like voice actors and
like the voice actors for like Batman um so it's gonna be
very very exciting I've always loved DC comics and I always
loved DC characters I've always loved like why don't we like
Batman per se I like Joker as a character I think Batman I
was just not like like you know he's just Batman but
honestly I feel I would I liked Joker more than Batman
because I felt like Joker was much of an interesting
character than he is he's just you know he's like a
billionaire depressed man who just you know number one rule
we don't kill anybody but i'll beat you up so hard that
you're you you'll have to deal with like millions of dollars
of hospital bills and on at least at the okay not gonna lie
his one rule being like i can't kill anybody but like i feel
like it's much worse being like ridden with like hospital
debt medical debt versus like you know like honestly for him
he doesn't care he's a fucking billionaire he doesn't have
to live through medical debt but like medical bills but but
an average criminal dealing with crippling medical debt is a
lot worse than just being dead and i feel like that you know
can be like wow batman that's so kind of you to not kill
them but i'm like at this point they might as well be dead
like he might as he owns the hot wait you're right that's so
fucked up batman if he owns the hospital that's pretty
fucked up oh my god this goes so deep anyway let's fucking
play Okay, I'll say, okay, what's the difficulty?
We'll do normal.
I'm going to do tough.
Oh, my God.
No, I don't want to deal with bullet sponges.
They should only be a type I hurt.
Expert, bro, okay.
This is not an FPS.
I don't want to deal with bullet sponges right now.
This game isn't old.
The Xbox 360.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe you're trying to bring up the Xbox right
now.
Now to...
Batman.
Okay, I'm gonna say it.
A lot of like the DC heroes, character-wise, they're pretty
bland.
Like, not just, sorry, not just DC heroes.
Marvel and DC heroes, some of them are incredibly bland when
it comes to like personality.
I feel like the villains are much more interesting.
Is this a Batman that uses guns?
There's a lot of them.
Whoa.
Oh, the volume's not too loud.
Sound check guy.
Help me.
Arkham.
There he is.
Oh.
Oh, joker.
Oh, a little quiet.
On the quiet side?
Oh, don't worry.
As long as the intro over oh my god you know the graphics
didn't age quite well for something that was 14 years ago i
think like okay hot take i think like a lot of the older
games look a lot better than the newer games because they
were not pressured to like make games a lot like they're not
pressured to make games in time for the holidays versus a
lot of the more recent games coming out
More camels!
That's warden shop to you.
Holes!
Yo, Frankie!
How's the wife?
It was before capitalism decided to take over the world.
Whoa!
Intensive treatment!
Not so tight, boys.
You'll crease the suit.
Get that filthy degenerate out of here.
Warden, something's not right.
I'm going with him.
I don't know.
I feel like, Batman, you're a billionaire.
I feel like this should be, like, better.
I feel like...
Should this be better funded?
I can't...
Whoa.
Okay, let me fix the...
Let me fix the...
Or...
Where the fuck...
Where's the sensitivity?
Is this it?
Oh my god.
were so much simple when it came to settings this is it what
the fuck that's it those are all my settings oh my god those
are all my settings holy shit okay i did not expect my
settings to be like not that much holy shit yeah i feel like
there's a lot of like uh like funding wise it feels like is
like Arkham Asylum.
Someone is taking too much of the funding from Arkham
Asylum.
Oh my god.
Okay, turn down voices by like 40.
Oh, turn down music by 40%.
And then 100% on the sound.
Okay, thank you soundcheck guy.
Just use your mod powers to tell me things.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
That's crazy.
I didn't realize there was like these were all the settings
and yeah, I forgot I forgot games were a lot simpler back
then there was like six things
Whoa Okay, not gonna lie If we were going to talk about
budget cuts This was this would be one of the things I would
cut Do we really need a picture of you Curing him will
cement my reputation Informed Dr. Young Curing him It's the
fucking Joker It's been like 60 plus years I don't think
After 60 plus years That we will ever cure Joker Look at all
this new security He's so had Warden Alright I was gonna say
I think you got I think you got like have a better standard.
Do we really need this elevator?
Stairs would work.
That is such a small elevator.
Stairs would actually work.
Or like a ramp.
We could have had a ramp.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Batman.
Financial wise.
This building is terrible.
He's on it.
That's what ramps are for!
That was like barely one meter.
Oh, zoom.
Nice.
What am I zooming in for?
Oh, him?
This actually, the graphics actually age so well.
It's called tax cuts.
I want weapons on him at all times.
Do not let him out of your sight.
There'll be time enough for you later, Cash.
Tick tock, tick tock.
Is that a crocodile like you?
Crock?
What's up, Doc?
Pencil me in for tomorrow at four.
We've got a lot of catching up to this.
When can I run?
Crafting.
Yeah, everything aged so well for a game that was 14 years.
go do we really need this tv okay financial wise like do we
really need all of this do we really need a tv at five ten
steps away warden why are the millions of dollars i pledge
for the asylum for shut up go catch you soon boss shut it
i'm telling you the state of the wiring This is so poorly
run.
This is...
No, this is...
Oh, now there's stairs.
I like how, like, now there's...
Now there's a use for stairs.
Satisfactory condition.
Looks like he suffered minor lacerations, probably in the
last two hours.
There seems to be...
Whoa.
Need to take my temperature?
I'd be happy to drop my pants.
I mean, I did just capture him.
But that's why there's like minor lacerations.
Wait, how's the sound now?
Soundcheck guy.
He ran out.
Was that Seabloom?
Oh my god.
I love Seabloom.
He's like, he has the best IMO.
I think he is the best Starscream voice actor.
You heard the lady.
We got another psycho on the way.
It's another psycho?
You hear that, Joker?
You're not fucking special.
What the fuck is that?
It must have been one of the guards then.
Is that in their elevator?
What the fuck is that?
Wait, who the fuck is that?
Is that Kroc?
Get ready.
What the fuck?
Where's his guard?
They let him in the elevator unsupervised?
Okay, Joker has like 10 guards on him, but Kroc has zero.
don't know priorities wise killer croc what's it doing yeah
how did he get here i've got your scent batman who the fuck
put him in the elevator by himself oh shit a toy color won't
stop me from killing you batman and rip you apart eat your
bones hell i okay okay now he gets two guards okay the guy
that's like you know not restrained gets two cards okay i
mean would you be in an elevator with i don't know i feel
like it's very dangerous to like have a villain by himself
on an elevator for that long unsupervised in general i feel
like that's like in hindsight that doesn't sound very smart
is young bats i still have a trick or two up my sleeve i
mean don't you think it's a little bit funny how a fire at
blackgate caused hundreds of my crew to be moved here i
thought i told you to stay quiet yeah frankie you really
you're not right here also i really don't think you should
antagonize joker tell me something you've never let me catch
you this easily What are you really after?
Well, nothing much.
Why second elevator?
There's a lot of... Why two TV screens?
You're asking about second elevator, but why are there two
TV screens?
I think, guys, there's a lot more questions to ask here.
What's he doing?
Stay where you are.
Guys, maybe we shouldn't have two TV.
What?
Course not, you're fucking Joker.
Batman literally was like, I've never caught you this easily
before.
Oh, hey, look.
See more guards.
You're back.
You killed three of my crew when you Busted out of here.
Okay, wait, let me bring up the overall sound first.
We gotta do justice to Mark Hamma.
Let me boost up the sound a little bit more.
Alright.
I hope this is a better sound guy.
The budget went to the TVs.
Oh?
Gordon?
Is this Commissioner Gordon?
Long night, Jim.
Joker invades City Hall and holds the mayor.
hostage leaving it to me to juggle swat teams the media and
you yeah it's been a hell of a night hopefully the last one
will ever have with him yeah harley hold it there sorry
batman arkham staff only i assure you if anyone's qualified
it's a listen i appreciate the assistance but he'll unsettle
the more violent inmates i think he's talking about you bats
don't be a stranger fair they are right I mean I'm pretty
sure Batman put all these criminals in the asylum okay he
surrendered almost without a fight I don't like it at least
he's back where he belongs yeah for like I don't know the
50th time he's in the asylum I feel like Joker it should be
like one of the villains that should just Just be like, be
in a prison just built for him.
Batman, there's a door!
Oh fuck!
There's a door!
I set a track and you sprang it gloriously!
Get this party started.
Alright.
Easy.
Wait, are normal grunts in the asylum too?
Okay, honestly, I don't know what the grunts were thinking
if that was smart.
Alright, I know you were- No!
Not done!
I'm not satisfied.
Oh, there we go.
Thanks.
I'm not satisfied.
Get over here.
Avoid damage by countering incoming.
Who needs to counter when I could just beat up everybody?
There's no need to counter when they're all dead.
The bug sapper.
I feel like it's more like the bat sapper.
Alright.
Nice.
How did I run?
No.
Oh.
Alright.
I honestly feel like the asylum should not have like regular
guys in here.
Is there a way to run?
Batman, please!
Can you only fucking walk?
Oh, okay.
Apparently prowling is faster.
Okay.
Wait, I could have literally had the door!
What the fuck did I smash the window?
They had keys!
Wait.
Oh, I can walk.
I can run as A.
Oh.
Why didn't you just come find me?
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I had to I had to, like, test that out for a sec.
What's the bio?
Police Commissioner James Gordon dedicated his career to
cleaning up the corruption in the Gothen City Police
Department.
A goal he has come long towards accomplishing.
He has been equally tough on crime and in pursuit of making
Gotham City safe for all his citizens.
Gordon has forged an uneasy alliance with Gotham's other top
crime fighter, the mysterious vigilante known as Batman.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there's a warden.
Wait, what are his facts?
Oh, shit, I'm going to dox him.
James W.
Gordon.
White okay oh that's interesting wait what's the joker's
real name unknown we don't know what the fuck what's the
point what about his medical records how is he going to pay
his medical bills quincy sharp has been running arkham
asylum for the past three years and has dedicated his life
to restoring to sanity the so-called super villains that
plague gotham city he's currently campaigned to become the
next mayor of gotham oh yeah he definitely he's definitely
only money laundering.
Yeah, this guy definitely looks like a guy that money
launders and bezels money.
Everywhere that madman goes, death is sure to follow.
Are they okay?
They can't be dead.
No one kills.
Oh, now they tell me how to run.
Warning.
Security breach in level B3.
There's no security.
I'm Batman.
Security breach.
How can there be security breach if I'm Batman?
Nice.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Oh, shit!
How are you still not dead?
Goodbye.
Not gonna lie, these guys have, like, zero armor.
They should not be like...
They should not take this long to beat up.
The Oracle.
He's running free in Arkham.
Do you need anything?
Is my dad still there?
Commissioner Gordon is safe.
Joker's not far ahead.
Wait, then where's this way?
Okay.
Which way is the right way?
Alright, where's this?
This goes.
Pacification chamber.
Where does this go?
Need contamination.
Oh shit.
Are you a good guy?
Hey Batman!
Over here!
Hello?
Eddie!
Why do you have a name?
I'm not supposed to humanize you.
You're just an NPC.
What happened?
Joker happened.
You're lucky to be alive.
He must have gone this way.
Doors jammed.
I'll try and get it open.
We need help in pacification.
Oh yeah, I know.
I know she can't walk anymore.
Can you hear me?
I'm with Batman.
Hello?
Where are they?
Back down there.
Do you need help?
No.
I work better alone.
Yeah.
I work better alone, and also the 500 adopted sons and one
and two adopted daughters.
I always, okay, so if you guys don't know, okay, Robin is
not the original Robin.
Dick is not the original Robin.
They, like, retconned and was, like, there was actually one
more.
I forgot her name, but she was, there was a female Robin
before Dick Robin.
And so now now there's two adopted daughters and 500 adopted
sons.
He works alone Third there's three adopted daughters Wait
here you can't he'll kill Mike if he sees anyone trying to
get close He won't see me That looks even a little bit like
a bat and this guy We can just get another guard.
He doesn't have a name.
What happens if I just run up?
Oh.
Okay.
All right, that happens.
All right.
But he's nameless.
It doesn't matter.
He has no name.
Does it really matter what happens to him?
There's three?
Who the fuck is the third Robin?
okay i guess i throw the batter on what else do i do all
right oh okay oh oh wait do i fail what no it's just one guy
who cares we don't even know his name Cena and the hostage
was killed.
We could just pay I'm a billionaire.
I could just pay his family.
I could compensate his family.
One, one, just one guy.
I'm a billionaire.
I could just compensate.
I could just raise his family.
He doesn't even have a name why should we care his name is
literally guard his name was mike okay what a fuck are you
focusing on names now you'll see me coming on the ground so
i'll stay up high yeah i have to use detective mode what's
this whoa whoa okay look around for its important objects oh
can i do something about that these old gargoyles should be
able to support my weight if i grapple up to them okay
gargoyles provide a suitable vantage point from which to
survey a room okay oh it's okay he's just getting zapped a
little bit glide cake to pour him a glide cake by focusing
on camera okay but what if he like zaps him a little bit
more it's mike from 20 years ago give him a little bit of a
zap zaz is down but not for long got to get close and take
it oh
bro i just made him a vegetable but he's not dead He's...
He's not dead!
Oh shit, it's the fucking embezzler.
Old Sharp has never been happier.
In case you ain't figured it out, today is the Joker's big
homecoming and you're the guest of honor.
You have one chance to surrender, Quinn.
Tempting best, but no dice.
Now the...
Okay.
Oh, how is it you're going to give me more updates?
Harley Quinn.
This is Harleen Quinzel.
An Arkham Asylum psychiatrist assigned to treat the Joker.
Dr. Harleen Quinzel instead became obsessively fixated on
her patient, believing herself to be in love with him.
She helped him escape confinement and took on her...
I can fix her.
I took on her own criminal identity as Harley Quinn.
Quinn is a violent unprotectual villain who's only not the
fucking $500,000 TVs that we fucking funded for the asylum
no don't worry that's why we have four TVs per room because
Quinn nature doesn't sell way mixture just another of his
victim a bit of very dangerous one I'm here Arkham Asylum
just vanished off the network he's in control of the
security system he's probably Isolated it from the grid
that's not all
one sets foot on the fuck now they figured out Also, who the
fuck wants to live in Gotham anymore?
I swear to God, I feel like Gotham City has like the
cheapest properties Because like it feels so depressing to
live in Gotham City at this point
I don't know After, like, I feel like the average death rate
in Gotham City is, like, at least, like, 500.
What the fuck?
I'm so fast.
It's, like, 500 per day.
Where the fuck are they still there?
At this point, I just...
I just live where Superman lives.
Like...
At least he can kill.
I live in a city where superheroes actually kill.
Yeah.
That's like a no kill bullshit.
It's just Chicago.
I'll live wherever.
I'll be like, do you kill?
Alright, nice.
Oh shit, are they dead?
Oh no, it's a laughing gas.
You can't afford him to travel.
What is that stuff?
Listen, the room is full of poison gas.
Anyone caught in there?
Anyway, let's open it.
Get in there and help them, Batman.
All right, how do I do this?
Oh, grapple.
Where?
Whoops.
Sucks to read them, I guess.
I can still see people alive in the room.
What happens if they all...
Can they actually all die?
Oh, God.
Just walk away!
Just stop looking!
Sir, look away!
Stop!
It's just trauma!
You don't have to look!
Oh, they can?
Oh, shit.
I was looking too hard.
Joker's been planning this.
You can't.
You're gonna let Steve die.
Who gives a fuck about?
Steve you're gonna be fine she doesn't even have a name he's
literally guard oh shit how the fuck do I get up here oh
shit Steve where's Steve Steve was trying to reach the vent
controls and clear the room when the explosion happened we I
care about Steve Alright, but how do I get the Riddler
Trophy?
Steve!
Steve, look, I'm sorry, but there is important matters.
Like, how do I get this trophy?
Okay, we gotta go downstairs.
But then there's laughing gas, so we gotta figure out how to
not get laughing gas.
Look up.
Look, I need to figure out the gas!
Oh, there's Steve!
There he is.
Trophy over Steve.
Yes, I'm I've never been a completionist, but today's the
day I changed.
You're the worst Batman ever?
Look, Batman has already been the worst Batman ever because
he doesn't kill.
Okay.
If he killed Joker 10 years ago, we would not be here.
So no matter what I do, Batman is already the worst Batman
he can be.
Yay!
Can't believe he left me here!
That son of a...
Okay, I cut over here.
Oh!
God!
I don't kill!
But I do give brain damage.
Clearly...
Clearly that's the best alternative.
Use to remove toxins...
Okay, but how do I remove it?
Terminal use...
There's the extractor control point.
Oh fuck!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Sorry, I tripped.
I tripped.
Everything's okay.
Okay.
You did a bad smash glass to activate it.
Can I just smash it like this?
Nice.
Sorry.
Okay.
I tripped.
Yay!
I did it!
The casualty's not that bad.
Alright, now I can get the trophy.
I did it!
Nobody doesn't stand a chance.
Yeah!
Look at that.
Sucks for all those other guys that died.
But, woo!
I did it!
Yeah!
Okay, how the fuck do I get the trophy?
It's somewhere here.
ow okay where is this where's the op switch oh there it is
can i just punch it no
where's the other guard hey there is anyone out there can
you hear me destroy the teeth why what's the teeth do to you
can i destroy it actually wait i can I don't answer.
I have unlimited.
Oh, wait.
What is that?
Plus 50?
Is that my currency?
You need a gadget that you don't have yet?
I'm Batman.
What do you mean I don't have yet?
I have money.
I can fix all my problems with money.
Oh, wait.
There's another one.
Oh.
Did I get it?
Oh, I did.
Nice.
Okay.
I wish I knew that earlier.
Backseaters!
You could have told me this earlier!
Slender.
Those are the bat bugs.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, is that the laughing gas?
Okay, causing a slow and painful death.
Oops.
Ha ha.
What the fuck gave him?
Paint cans.
Oh, bat teeth.
Oops.
Okay.
Sorry.
Thank God they're unlimited.
My budget.
50 million on Battle Rags.
Alright, guys.
Someone help me budget this.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
I wish Batman has guns.
There we go.
He's dead?
Oh, he is definitely dead.
Oh, fuck.
He is definitely dead.
nice Gotham City is sometimes like New Jersey I wait any New
Jersey people out there want a fucking vouch for that what a
fuck gave Joker spray cans oh teeth no teeth what chickens
are love
there's no escape Oh, now I can't aim.
After 200 years.
Who's that?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck is this guy?
Boom.
Double tap direction to evade.
Holy shit!
You can just throw people?
Ow!
Okay, evade.
Where the fuck?
What do I do?
Oh, shit!
Okay, don't worry.
I'm unlimited veterans!
What is he gonna do?
Fucking punch me?
Okay.
it's fine this is my gun now use your fist why use my fist
when I can throw better eggs oh shit how the fuck is my fist
stronger than metal like you're right just call Superman
honestly I feel like all my problems could just be fixed if
I call Superman like I need to make sure like pride and ego
should not be wait was Is that it?
Oh, fuck.
How is my fist stronger than fucking metal?
From sheer physics, my battle run should be stronger.
Physics w- that's a blade!
Oh, you're getting too predictable bats.
Well, I'd love to stay in chat, but I have a party to
organize.
Throw your bat rings!
Bat-bat, what are you doing?
He can't dodge five!
He got the money punch.
That is a bat run.
Yeah, this does not look nice.
Yeah.
It's not natural.
Oh, shit.
I can upgrade.
All right.
You have unlocked a Wayne Tech upgrade.
Batman ignores physics.
Bad Tokyo's backseat.
Yes, because it's stupid.
What did he throw his batter eggs?
He could have ended it all.
I don't know if he doesn't want to kill it.
Fucking throw it at his fucking leg or something.
some shit like it doesn't have to be lethal okay fill the xp
meter to upgrade the bats and gain enhanced skills yes wing
tech all right wing tech oh wait that's the map oh my god
thank god there's a map i'm always directionally challenged
all right what do we oh it's just a linear upgrade oh wait
no no there's not okay combo batterang critical combo
strikes all right what do we backseaters rise up what do we
upgrade first backseaters this is it what do we upgrade
first this is your time to shine there's so many stuff
inverted takedown the fuck is that remote control remote
control bataran sorry apparently fucking physics sucks in
this game that bat arounds mean nothing.
Invert takedown.
Okay, allows Batman to swoop down and grab a stainless as
they pass under gargoyles and leave them.
Oh!
Wait, that's so cool.
Okay.
I can just, like, be up top and not have to worry.
Nice.
Alright, pick up the Riddler trophy.
Is there anything else here?
Detective mode.
Anything else I'm missing?
Who is this?
Is this Eddie?
Eddie?
Oh, sorry, you don't matter too.
Wait, he literally has Eddie's eyes!
Oh, Jerry has a name.
Joker went through that door.
What's on the other side?
We call it extreme isolation.
Only way in is via the transport system.
I love how they gave Jerry a name, but not guard number 20.
Alright, nice.
thank you guard can i go back and grab the teeth no joker
you're expecting maybe two things there's no escape joker
silly bat i don't want to escape them having way too much
fun i even have you here to give a smile on my face not for
long really we'll see this is a very unhealthy relationship
joker just in case you were planning on a range
No!
Officer Balls is corrupt?
Gordon, your whole job was to deal with corruption!
Have you tried to follow me?
He dies.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, Gordon's terrible at his job, too.
I should go back to the holding cells.
Balls wasn't too smart.
Gordon, your one fucking job was to deal with of corruption!
How did this happen?
Alright, we gotta go locate and analyze the holding cells
for evidence.
Alright.
I gotta look at that map a lot.
Where's the teeth?
No, my XP.
Joker's escaped.
He sealed himself off.
He's got your father.
Dad.
Don't worry, I'm getting him back.
He's doing his best.
At this point, I feel like we have to hire another
commissioner.
Joker will not win.
I won't let him.
I'm starting where he was taken if he was a good cop He
would not be stationed at Gotham City If you think about it
You think about it, he would have 100% been promoted outside
of Gotham City Wait, do I have like enough to upgrade for
anything else?
No, I know Like he would have been stationed in metropolis I
bet you're wondering how I did it How do you do it?
Not gonna lie.
Batman should never...
I should not have the title of Great Detective with my track
record.
What the
fuck is...
How corrupt is this place?
Batman!
Just have better funding!
You're literally a billionaire!
Outsource Outsource the metropolis To get fun Is that
actually too hard to do?
Just throw money at the problem Outsource.
Oh hey the penguin Iceberg lounge Very hard Two hostiles?
Oh they're over there Okay Three TVs Wait that's true what
if What the fuck was there three TVs?
He cat outfund the embezzlement.
Shit, you're fucking right.
This is a bigger issue than it should be.
Oh, throw about until the end time.
Use a quick throw.
Wait, how do I use...
Oh.
Oh, okay, I just do that.
my fucking veterans are so weak like brain damage all right
goodbye there's a lot of issue
there is this is a huge problem batman this is a huge
problem
oracle i'm at the holding cells i'm setting up a crime scene
so what's the plan isolate something in that room unique to
both exactly in the crime scene use detective mode to search
for evidence okay evidence scanner am i scanning aborted
okay where am i scanning where the fuck do i need to scan
i'm in the right place ow isolate something i can link to
the guard that clubbed gordon wait where did he get clubbed
oh there you go what the is that let's see what the forensic
scanner picks up alcohol traces of wait were you drinking in
the atmosphere i've got a trail that's great you follow it
i'm grabbing maybe this is why you got fucking clubbed hey
uh track gordon moves by following bowls oh no he was
drinking he had alcohol strength i see use detective mode oh
everything else deceased what the fuck is that use detective
mode to follow wait there's more
the whiskey trails where the fuck is the whiskey trails I
literally see one whiskey oh there it is ow okay let's just
fucking can I chop this boom no I cannot Guys, give me a
sec, I'm thinking.
Break the window.
The window's already broken.
Can I jump out?
No.
Okay, now I can't jump out.
Alright.
No, scan it?
Let me cook.
Don't worry, I'll figure this out.
I'm the greatest detective.
Don't worry.
Like they said, I'm the fucking greatest detective out
there.
Oh.
Alright, there's more alcohol.
There we go.
I'm figuring it out, guys.
Yeah, there's more here.
There's more here.
Oh, I'm following it.
Oh my god, Joker.
He's a computer engineer, too.
He can hack things.
Oh my god, he can do everything.
Oh, enemy?
Are you a good guy?
I can't see.
I'm in detective mode.
Jury,
is that you?
Be quiet.
I'm detectiving.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, B-Man.
Mr. J doesn't want you following us just yet.
I missed teeth?
No!
Not the teeth!
Oh, shit.
I can fix her.
Where's the teeth?
Oh, teeth!
Give me a sec, Harley.
Harley, I literally have grapple!
If I want to follow them, I'll need to do this the
old-fashioned way.
Harley, I literally have grappling.
Like, how is that going to stop me, Harley?
Wait, wait, where the stairs goes?
Wait, there's stairs?
Harley, there's stairs!
Oh my god, you have a name!
Henry Smith!
This is Joker's doing.
Who else?
I told him he's a monster.
It's slower, though.
all right let's see you know what let's try to grapple first
it's it's faster than stairs i feel like that is a lot
faster unless wait are you trying to tell me there's no more
else to grapple no then what's the point what well shimmy oh
all right can i here.
I know you can hear me.
I've got a little something for you to listen to.
What is a joker?
Let's have a listen, shall we?
Hey, Frank, breathe in.
Joker's got more men on the way.
They're coming around the front of the asylum.
Gotta stop them.
Get in.
Quick, get over there.
Come on, everyone.
Cover the main entrance.
Oh.
This is important.
Oh!
Bulls!
Frank, what are you doing?
No, the corruption!
Wait,
is Joker a cop?
No!
Oh, I'm alive!
Okay, everything's fine.
Yay!
They're dancing!
They're cute!
No!
Okay, everything's fine.
Okay,
let's see.
Oh, let's shoot me again, Joker guy.
I'm gonna say...
That's a little...
A little awkward.
Alright, how the fuck do I get to the fucking...
Riddler trophy doesn't really matter okay guys under for
under for achievements what does the trophy get me what what
does the trophy get me other than achievements I need a no
just for unlocks what does it unlock nothing okay I'll never
look at another true oh XP oh fuck okay I need XP actually
never mind XP is nice run towards low walls or fences to
climb them Oh, like this?
Nice.
Let's see.
God, I'm so confused right now.
There's too many entrances.
The feeling of accomplishment.
Look, I'm already doing it for the achievements.
I mean, for the XP, okay?
Is that not enough?
Actually, I don't know.
I'm going to go through.
There's so many areas to go to.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Holly, why the fuck did you...
I should have taken the stairs.
God fucking damn it.
The stairs would have been easier.
The stairs would have been 100% easier.
Where am I?
Where?
Oh, shit.
What is this?
wall that i can't do anything about what the fuck oh what do
i how do i destroy it structurally weak if it's structurally
weak why would my fist destroy it a controlled oh it's for
later god damn it it's for later god damn it all right yes i
won't have to go there yet.
I don't have the upgrades, guys.
I'm poor, apparently.
Escape?
Oh.
I did it.
Mine, uh...
I did not do it.
Oh, shit.
No, they're alive.
Okay.
Where the fuck?
Where do I go?
Shimmy?
Wait, oh, shimmy!
Oh my god, there's a shimmy!
I'm learning.
Guys, I'm getting better.
Why didn't they appoint fucking Superman in Gotham City?
I feel like I'm just in the wrong city at this point.
I feel like if the crime rate is like 80 i think i'm doing i
think my i'm not doing a very good job i don't think i was
meant to be a superhero just think about it guys the crime
rate is still so hot then what's the point
thank you maybe he's actually not good at what he does
Warning.
Arkham intensive treatment is under emergency law.
But don't give Harley is evil.
Why?
Because only evil people are hot.
Let's see.
Oh, there it is.
Jesus Christ.
Sometimes.
Alright.
I got it.
I figured it out.
i'm slowly learning
also where the fuck is robin is this before i had kids
what's this what is that is this another thing i need to
upgrade hold and scan oh deciphered messages okay i am the
spirit of armadale's arkham I need to steal more kids.
Oh, shit.
Where my own curse is to forever remain in the shadows.
My story is carved into the very soul of Arkham.
And will only be revealed to those dedicated enough to
discover it.
Oh, shit.
All right, where is it?
Backseaters, it's your time.
Okay.
Hello.
All right.
Time to beat up goo number five.
Oh.
All right.
Hey, look.
Billionaires are not supposed to be, like, good fighters.
We just throw money at things.
Oh, shit.
All right.
Don't let him hit you, you idiot.
Goodbye.
Where's my gun update?
Nope.
Not yet, but I'm getting close.
Twain tried to slow me down.
Dropped an elevator on me.
Did it work?
Of course not.
I'll get back to you when I reach the end of the trail.
Alright.
Teeth.
Oh, bent.
There's like so many passageways around here.
I'm getting so confused.
I mean, there's a lie.
Okay, locked, locked.
Nice alcohol.
All right, we have to go to the event then.
Oh, no.
I feel like I'm going to get more lost later.
I have a feeling.
Whoa, shit!
Wait, he has a gun?
Wait, who's that?
That's not fair.
Batman!
Is it people are dying and you don't want to use a gun?
Okay.
It should be a life for a life if they get to kill two
people.
I get to kill two people like I feel like no I can run.
Oh shit.
I cannot run.
I'm not faster than a bullet
Guys I found out Batman's not faster than bullets I know
I'll calibrate the cowls vision mode to isolate great.
They can't walk forward side i need to be smart find a
different way past them oh gargoyle okay let's see gargoyle
gargoyle gargoyle okay tap down drop down silently but what
if i can kill
but i want to kill okay but like what if i do this Nice.
What are you gonna do?
Oh shit!
No!
That's not silent!
Okay, but what if I do this?
Oh!
I don't think they like that.
I don't think...
Okay.
Wait, they're not... God damn it.
That's so fucking weak.
No!
What the...
Okay.
They will never know.
But they'll never know.
They'll never know.
Stuff.
Hey.
I wonder where Batman is.
Okay.
Oh, she!
Ah!
Sorry.
I got a little cocky there.
Okay.
That's a little stupid.
I'm gonna lie.
That's a little fucking stupid.
Wait, there's a person there.
No problem.
They'll never know.
Yes, we need to set a trap.
I suppose I better warn my boy.
It'll be a nice surprise.
I know I think they'll enjoy it too.
I mean, they already have guns.
Don't worry, they'll be fine.
Wayne Tech.
Wait, does this develop by me?
Are you considered hack proof?
Currently inactive.
That is a fucking lie.
The Joker literally hacked several things.
What do you mean?
Wayne Tech.
Wayne Tech!
You are not, I'm not a great billionaire.
To be fair, I feel like I like as Bruce Wayne, I definitely
outsource everything.
There's no way I have enough time to run a company if I'm
out here doing all this all right what do we need to upgrade
welcome to corporate America how we got that TV this asylum
has look look there's a lot of things wrong with Gotham City
in general all right guys it's time it's time backseaters
times two combo which one Where is it?
Critical strike?
Where is that?
What we've learned is that batter heads don't fucking work.
Which one's the best one?
Army?
Critical strikes?
Wait, next to inverted?
Oh, there you go.
Wait, I don't have enough.
How much is that?
I'm broke?
How the fuck do I up on the deck?
Sorry guys, I don't have enough money apparently.
How much XP are this?
There's no- I- I have a thousand bat bucks!
$1,000 is- okay, what the fuck is the exchange rate of bat
bucks?
Apparently the bat bucks exchange rate is pretty fucking
poor right now.
Uncle Jay!
We have an escaped patient!
Oh my dangerous, I don't even have a gun!
I don't even- okay, I don't even kill.
I should not be dangerous at all if I can't even kill.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Oh.
I just slap him once and that's good.
But let's see.
All right, how do I kill this guy?
Inverted takedown.
There it is!
Oh!
Nice.
Okay, not gonna lie, this can actually kill a person.
Batman, you idiot!
If they leave hanging way too long, the blood will go all
the way to the head, and then he'll die!
Batman!
Oh, shit.
It's just a slower death, Pepe!
Don't you understand?
Oh, he doesn't look up.
Gamers don't look up.
No, no, it'll be fine.
Don't worry.
PimD doesn't look up, right?
Ooh, glad kick.
It's fine.
It's Oscar.
But who's gonna let him down?
There's no guards here.
Batman's gonna get up, his heart's gonna stop Batman!
Gravity killed him, not Batman!
That's true.
It's not my fault, it's gravity's fault.
Gamish, don't look up!
Oh
Oh, shit, please I'm still beating someone out please no
Okay, that was a mistake
No joker you can't finish me off Okay, wait freezing.
Sorry Wait, where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh Where am I?
Where is this place?
I don't know where I am Oh, it's this one that's do this all
over again.
Are you fucking okay.
I have to listen to him?
It's fine.
There's no way he'll hear this That's fine.
He doesn't hear this.
Don't worry.
They learn how to look up in the third wait you mean they
actually learn to be fair i think that is what joker wants
though with how the he does his stuff i'm just glad to kick
this guy get over here
oh no no no stop he's still shooting i thought they don't
look up wait where did he go where is he he was a glad kick
what the do they have guns now things were so easier yeah i
said a few more my boys you're
All right, where are the other ones?
Is this supposed to do a stealth section?
No, we don't stealth here if we've learned how Doki plays.
There's no...
Wait, why am I not on the gargoyle?
There's no such thing as stealth.
All right, let's see.
I won't know I'm up here, right?
Okay, get over here.
Get over here.
Come on.
Walk over here.
Gravity will kill you.
Come on.
It won't be so bad.
That's right.
Yeah, no, no, no.
Come on.
Leave it right here.
Just a little to the left You're almost there Are you okay?
He doesn't want to I don't think he wants to Alright don't
worry I got this one over here Alright Come on a little to
the right you know you want to you don't know you want to
throw a batter i'm not gonna throw a batter oh wait wait
wait wait here here you're here come on you have to oh nice
all right nice okay i told eventually eventually it'd work
what's he gonna do look up over the other side.
What are we going to do?
What is he going to do?
Wait, can they cut it down?
Just shoot the rope.
We'll come back when the bat is dead.
We'll come back.
Okay.
Shoot the rope.
Just shoot the rope.
Alright, nice.
Now he's going to walk to me.
Oh, I can cut the rope?
Okay.
oh my god this changes everything okay we're gonna oh my god
he's paranoid nice all right goodbye
brain damage oh no that is that's his dick okay that's
that's a little bit worse
oh interview call me harley everyone does i'm surprised
Thank you.
Congrats on 500k subscribers.
Thank you!
I can't believe we broke 500k subscribers.
I'll warn you right now.
These are hardcore psychotics.
Most would rather kill you than speak to you.
One or two of them will enjoy it too.
Be careful.
Oh shit, the Riddler.
I never got to meet him.
Oh my god.
I recently watched the new Batman movie with Robert
Patterson and like okay okay the Riddler's fucking outfit I
was like why the fuck is he wearing BDSM gear I was like is
that a GIP I can open doors oh wait no what at where oh It's
like stealth Yeah, like the new In the rhythm in that new
Batman I don't, I don't fuck with his outfit That I don't
know Just ain't right To me Not saying you're wrong
No, no
Like his, his I don't know I just I don't It made me very
uncomfortable What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Is that him?
Who's that over there?
Whoops, sorry.
Who's that?
Deceased.
Do you think the other guy's okay?
Dead end.
Oh, shit.
Gordon's moving by following Bull's Whiskey Trails.
Let me grab some tea first.
Can I, like, do it fast?
No.
I can nice oh yes but I don't kill
we take my fucking ass and more importantly your
intellectual superior my genius has allowed me to easily
hack into your perimeter what the fuck we tech you complete
a series of amusingly taxing challenges and well you'll see
ready for your first one That's my first one.
But be careful.
Don't cut yourself on this sharply observed portrait.
Object detected?
I said.
Don't cut yourself on this sharply observed portrait.
Oh, shit.
Did the stream die?
It's okay.
I'm back.
What the fuck?
What other portraits are there?
What are they?
No!
Oh, I'm back.
Okay.
The Riddler broke the screen, but don't worry, we're back.
Oh, isn't this portrait?
There's another portrait right here.
Oh, wait, no, not that one.
Yeah.
I would have expected a child to work that one out, let
alone the world's greatest detective.
Where did I win?
What the fuck did I win?
Whereas you don't know Jack about the utility corridor.
Jack, about Gotham.
Tune in to find out.
What did I win?
Really?
What the fuck did I win?
Okay, let's see.
Do I have enough for upgrades yet?
Oh, I need like $20.
Oh,
XP?
I love XP.
Anything else I can do?
Hello.
Do you have a name?
Oh my god, William!
There was a massacre.
Balls came walking in telling everyone to cover the front
entrance.
Said something about Joker's army coming through the main
gate.
Two of my guys moved to the exit and Frank shot him dead.
They never stood a chance.
Was Balls alone?
Thought he was.
Then I saw Harley Quinn.
She was surrounded by Black Gate prisoners.
They were just killing everyone.
I had no choice.
I got in here.
Lock the door.
Don't worry.
William I'll never kill like them even though all your
friends are dead good good he was scum don't worry I'll look
after Maria what a fuck is Maria oh my take his wife?
Bro, what the fuck?
He's dead!
That's fucked up, man.
Don't worry, my best friend, Maria will be safe with me.
That's messed up.
I don't think he would want you to take care of her.
I don't Alright, get over there.
Ooh.
God damn it, I'm still weak as fuck.
Anything here?
No.
Uh...
Alright, I had no...
No!
No, John!
You're dead!
Anyway...
Now I feel like he wanted him to be dead.
What the fuck is Jack Rider?
I'm going to go in the Gotham Bay.
Scan.
No scan.
Call his bluff.
He's not crazy enough to do it.
Call the
bluff.
No one lives in that mansion anyway.
Just Alfred.
It's just one guy.
The audio keeps cutting in and out.
Wait, is that true?
Or is it just your YouTube?
Is it just your YouTube?
All right, we need the critical combo.
No, not.
Alfred.
Did you know in the comic series, he's been dead for five
years now?
Apparently.
Oh, it's just that guy.
Yeah, you got, I got one guy.
One guy.
I think you gotta check your PC.
Tell that one guy to check his PC.
One guy.
I think you gotta upgrade your PC, sir.
Oh, I can open doors.
Spoilers?
It's not a spoiler.
It's a, okay.
You were never gonna read the fucking comic anyway you know
how i learned about that from youtube shorts all right
eventually the youtube short algorithms you'll find out okay
you'll find out you don't know that oh yeah when was the
last time you read a fucking batman comic you do know people
have not been reading comics in a long time The comic
industry is fucking dying.
You, you are not gonna change.
You're the reason why the comic industry is dying.
I'm the reason why the comic industry is dying.
I literally, I literally just watched YouTube shorts to get
by comic lore.
Oh, people read the, read the, it's sad, but it's true.
youtube shorts
oh shit is poison ivy gonna be here
you're right but still they booed her because she was right
oh there's a garden in the asylum oh no this is outside
never mind i was like i thought i was still like inside for
some reason i thought that was just a really big green
okay escape from intensive treatment to the island surface
nice those my guards all right two hostiles two armed zero
unarmed no these are my people okay these are not my whoa oh
it's okay i have the bat cave nice
it's me batman
Can I scan a person?
No.
He doesn't matter, apparently.
Okay, you guys saw it.
Scan Wing Tech.
How the... Oh!
Alert!
Batmobile sensor?
Where's my car?
Oracle.
Disable the Batmobile's countermeasure system.
I saw the alert.
What's wrong?
Where are you?
I'm outside the Arkham Mansion.
Harley Quinn probably triggered the alarm.
If she still got Gordon with her, he could get hurt.
Okay, done.
The Batmobile is still parked up outside the intensive
treatment building in arkham north i've sent you the
schematics for the entire island i've marked key oh my god
there's a lot of things in front of me
this is a big map protect the batmobile okay medical
facility pentane arkham mansion all right people are saying
i should scan the wane let me scan it let me scan it wait
how do i zoom again Okay, there you go.
Come on.
You know you want to scan it.
Real stop.
Yay!
I didn't even have to read your riddle.
I have backseaters.
I can look up about myself.
Okay.
Where's my bio?
Where is my billionaire bio?
Bruce Wayne.
Born into a wealthy Wayne family.
Bruce Wayne had an idyllic childhood.
Although he was giving me strong Have I... Has Bruce Wayne
ever graduated a university?
Does he even have a master's degree in business?
But his moral alistic and philophtrap parents, Thomas and
Martha.
After their violent murder at Crime Alley, Bruce dedicated
his life.
He bought one to palling the cruel element that took their
lives.
Yeah, it hasn't really helped much.
left Gotham for many years to train his mental and physical
abilities across the globe.
Before final returning, take up the mantle of the Dark
Knight.
It doesn't say he even has an education.
Why do you think he... Because he's running a fucking
billionaire company.
I feel like you should have some sense of business sense.
You know?
I don't know.
Am I crazy to think that?
I'm not...
is that too out of line to ask him to see if he has a
business a master's degree he signs paper they're here
expecting too much he just signs the papers they give him
the documents and then that is it yeah but don't you think
he has to read the documents guys is that too much if he's
gonna sign it he has to read it too right like right he has
people to do that for him oh shit not the ambulance guys are
guys okay i can't believe it they killed jackson Jackson!
Guard Dumper 5?
Oh my god!
The dead guy has a name!
That's so fucked up.
No!
Jackson!
Oh shit!
Where's the gun?
Sorry, I didn't have my fucking detective mode on
apparently.
all right let me get him on all right there you go poop
goodbye and you only have you get named when you die
apparently you know you have no importance until you're dead
oh twiddledee and twiddled dumb saw it can you see it no not
my fucking car
Jackson has been a pen.
Bro, my car is...
I have no insurance.
There's a lot of cutbacks here.
Why don't I get my car to work?
Hello.
Oh, they don't have guns.
Wait, they don't have guns.
This is good.
I guess I'll just beat them up.
It's okay, guys.
No gun!
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
Boop.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I'm disoriented.
I'm disoriented right now.
It's fine.
Just take his pipe.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
All right.
Punch him in the dick.
Punch him in the head.
Easy.
Nice.
That was easy.
There's a supply of explosive gel.
Oh my god.
Well.
Rest in peace, my car.
Collect explosive gel.
Can we use this destroy structure?
Oh, shit, nice.
I can finally destroy walls now.
Explosives may harm.
May.
Okay, but like, we don't care about that, right?
hurt me people eventually they were gonna die eventually my
insurance no there could be a clue as to where she took
gordon i just think i don't have insurance because why the
fuck would you insure a batmobile because like what's the
point because then what's the point of having a secret
identity we try insuring a batmobile
what am i supposed to scan
self-repair.
Wait, does do I even have a license plate?
My god, I don't even have it licensed.
Okay, this evidence scanner.
All right, backseaters.
Stay in the orange.
Okay, but where the...
Where am I supposed to scan?
Do I own an insurance company?
share myself oh Gordon's pipe oh there's no way he'd leave
it is it does he carry a pipe with him Gordon's favorite
tobacco Gordon smarter than he looks left me a trail to
follow Oracle I found a pipe it has your father's initials
carved on it it was a birthday gift I gave him last year
really no way he'd leave it exactly Look, it's... I don't
need to detect anything when I have these fists.
How do I destroy this?
What's that rule, Joker?
It's a secret.
Did I not have the explosive gel already?
I do!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I can just do this.
Boop.
Oh, I detonate it.
Oh, that's just Batarang.
Okay, LT to prepare explosive gel.
They're not prepared it.
They're not prepared enough.
Oh!
Okay.
I'm learning.
I drew the bat sign on it.
Batman, please.
Time and place.
It's gonna be blown up anyway.
Batman please who's looking at this it's just you and I
brand you don't get it dokey it's branding who's gonna look
who's gonna look at the brand
who's gonna look at the brand tell me but the style
Batman is a panksy to who who's sending that message to you
where am I supposed to go locate Gordon but oh track is okay
there it is
we are I'm going to have to find another way around to get
back on anything up top so he knows which whose gel it
belongs to yeah but i want to know if there's anything here
who's this oh kate it's
his king sorry that's
him the
chockler what a fuck is that other guy you
can have everything that is a lie there are things you
cannot cure who the fuck higher the psychiatrist there is
that is a fucking lie there is some mental disorders you
cannot cure who what are her credentials it's not fucking
physical it's in there oh my god don't trust don't trust a
psychiatrist that's like anything can be cured you know what
can't be fucking cured can't oh wait no cancer can be
depending on what type of cancer never mind rabies rabies
can't be cured doctor what about rabies oh wait let's see
thanksy time alright that's what i'm saying don't trust a
doctor that says anything can be cured that's just giving
false hope rabies do it can't when you get rabies you
fucking die oh it can it can kind of all right if you say it
can kind of that doesn't mean
time okay if it's cotton time yes but like it doesn't mean
it's curable all the time
all right
i'm gonna like unlock it from the outside or inside
nothing exactly that's what i mean that's why you don't
trust any psychiatrist or doctor that says anything can be
cured that's just like malpractice point where are the
enemies eight hoss eight oh shit wait whoa can i head there
now ow whoops nope trust no one not even doctors actually no
please trust your doctors please don't do home remedies oh
Scan.
Wait, are these good guys?
Oh, they are definitely not good guys.
Don't worry.
They won't be able to see me when I walk very slow up to
them, right?
Hello.
Yeah, he's too busy working.
He won't know.
No either.
Wait, what are they building?
What is this?
Are they trying to improve the structural integrity of this
building?
And why am I silencing them?
Did it?
Why?
They just carpenters, Doki.
What the fuck is wrong?
What are you?
They're just trying to fix the structure.
I can't believe it.
We gotta cancel, Batman.
Is he okay?
Are you okay?
Batman, what's going on?
The crazies are moving towards the medical facility.
Yeah, but I want to talk to this one guy.
He's trying to take over the island piece by piece.
It looks like medical is his next target.
Has anyone got out of the building?
I saw a doctor try.
Can't believe it.
Batman's against fucking handyman.
He's a chance.
Against trade schools.
I want to talk to this one guy.
I want to see he has a name.
Alright.
I'll go inside.
What?
Me?
No.
Wait, go inside.
What's inside?
Hello?
Whoa.
Take off your mask.
So, Bats, I was thinking.
You really could use a friend in here.
Someone to talk to.
There's any friends.
That's why he adopts kids.
To fill that hole in his heart.
Who is that behind the mask?
Why do you feel the need to go out into the world and fight
people like me?
Do you really think you could win?
We'll see.
Wait, this is first-person now.
That's interesting.
Where do I go, though?
Huh?
Can't do anything here.
Oh, is it only this building?
Is that it?
Do I leave?
Okay.
Joker?
Oh, you come back later.
Oh, it's an Easter egg.
It's just to talk to Joker.
I was gonna say.
I was gonna say, like, what do I do next?
That's interesting.
That's, that's, like, first person.
Go back inside later.
Is it trying to turn into, like, some fucking horror film?
Alright, where's the tobacco?
Oh, there it is.
There's six hostiles, six unarmed.
Oh, they're unarmed!
They don't have guns!
It's time to beat them up.
They don't have guns.
This is perfect.
Wait, what's over there?
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of dead people.
Joki, you already said that again.
It wasn't funny the first time.
It wasn't cool.
Wait.
You know what?
I'm just gonna beat them up for XP.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
guns.
I ain't scared.
You don't have guns.
Oh, shit, you have teeth.
Give me a sec.
Nice.
I love body mashing.
Alright, no!
Fuck, okay.
Oh, shit.
No!
Alright, we're fine.
Dick punch.
Alright.
Brain damage.
It's fine.
I might get a little bit of brain damage, too.
But I'm a streamer, so it's, like, part of the job.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Wait, where's the other one?
Where's the other teeth?
Oh my gosh, so hard to see the teeth.
You can't see thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you!
Potato.
That's me.
god like honestly i feel like i should have like a a life to
life a life to life exchange if they get to kill two people
i get to kill two people because like i'm pretty sure this
is like 10 families already just in this geno vicinity i
like i have to like pay for 10 extra families
Open door.
Harley!
Hey there.
Hey there, girl.
Where's Gordon?
Wouldn't you like to go?
Oh.
Wait, where is he?
Pudding!
I can fix her.
Oh, they're definitely...
They definitely like to have a warrior, too.
Oh, yeah, they're freaky.
They're definitely freaky.
Yeah, it's Tara Strong.
Before she got super weird.
Okay.
The one of the weirdest shit about her is that, like...
Okay, this is what's my gripe.
about Tara strong oh it's not it's not her oh shit it's not
okay but anyway there is like there's the one of the weird
shit about what her is that she was like no AI voices so
because it hurts the voice acting industry and then later on
she was like but AI art is okay I thought I thought that was
like pretty weird not I can't pick and choose that.
I just thought that was fucking weird.
I don't know about you.
I feel like if you have any stats regarding a certain thing,
I feel like you shouldn't pick and choose.
That's Arlene.
I thought that was Tyra's job because like, usually they get
Tyra's job.
for Harley Quinn.
Alright, let's see.
Search for a structural weakness in the exterior.
At this point, everything should be a structural weakness in
this fucking city.
Alright, let's see.
But now 14 years ago.
Wasn't Tyra Strong like the original voice actor actress for
Harley Quinn?
I thought she was when the original animated series or was
it or was it Arlene oh Arlene was the original?
Oh okay I didn't know that.
That's Arlene.
Why is Arlene not as popular?
Okay Batman.
Alright dead neat.
Nice.
Oh, she's She passed away Okay, that makes a lot more sense
I didn't know that
I think I like how Like Mark Hamill like retired Joker When
Kevin Conroy Passed away Because like that's very respectful
Can I break this
That's fucked up Being a doctor is very hard Joker He spent
like at least 10 years to get that degree, man.
We don't have enough people, Joker.
If we don't have doctors in Gotham City, then, like, who the
fuck is gonna patch you up?
There's not enough veterinarians for that.
Yeah.
Oh, this way.
Wait.
How am I supposed to get the fucking trophy?
Where am I going?
He said...
He said death, Joker.
Oh, nice.
Trophy time.
Veteranarians?
Yeah, you don't know that?
I learned this from a movie.
But, like, sometimes the mob used the veterinarians to patch
them up illegally, so they don't have to go through a real
doctor.
Obviously, movies are true.
Obviously, what you see in the movies is what's actually
going on.
Who's that guy?
Is that a doctor?
Why does he need the doctor?
I've got to save them.
We do.
True.
Oh, inverted takedown.
Whoa, shit!
You don't see it!
They don't see it!
They don't see!
Whoa!
Don't worry, I'm too fast.
Too fast.
Oh, wait.
And we should not have done that, actually.
Oh, hey.
He doesn't know.
Oh, that's a lot of people.
Oh, okay.
That is a lot of people.
Can I do more than one person?
Wait, where's the doctor?
What if I actually kill the doctor?
Can I?
Okay, this is science reasons.
Okay.
Okay, no, she's safe.
I just wanted to know.
Because what if I accidentally kill her?
You know?
I'm just trying to make sure I don't accidentally kill
anybody.
Alright, I'm totally gonna get shot at when I do this.
Stealth mission.
I'm in pretty stealthy like this, right?
Come on.
Get over here.
Wait.
Oh, there you go.
Yay.
Don't worry, I'll just fly.
Just keep flying.
He doesn't know.
Okay.
Yeah, after.
It's all about after.
Okay, maybe I...
Can I make them go over there?
Can I make them walk over there?
Oh, I can!
He's not going to look up.
Trust me.
Come on.
Head down here.
You know you want to.
Come on.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
It's just two more steps.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, okay.
I can do it here.
I was going to be like, that's fucked up.
I got lied to.
Okay.
I might hit it here.
Yeah, come over here.
You know you want to.
You know you want to walk over there.
Come on.
Oh, fuck it.
I can't.
I'm not patient enough for this.
Fuck this.
His teammate's not going to be helping him anyway.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Now he's not gonna...
Wait, is it?
Is he gonna shoot me?
No, he can't tell.
Is that the last guy?
Alright.
Wee!
Get over here.
Nice.
I did it.
Doctors!
What is going on?
I did it, doctors!
looks like harleen with the hair every red hair girl harleen
harley quinn did they have anyone with them they took
someone into the elevator i couldn't tell who it was they
obviously didn't want to be followed the elevator appears to
have been powered down you're going to be okay here we'll be
fine what about the others we heard gunfire they could be
dead we should go and help oh no i forgot Harley's blonde?
Okay, I'm thinking about red hair, Harley.
Oh, no, I'm thinking about poison ivy hair.
Okay, sorry.
I was watching Harley Quinn earlier and, like, my hair
colors got mixed up.
I was thinking about poison ivy.
I'm gonna say newest season of Harley Quinn Pretty fucking
shit.
The writing for that was got fucking weird.
Oh, interview tape.
Fake fat.
Oh, I'm sorry, Mr. I didn't know Alfred died five years ago
and was never brought back.
Patience name is Edward Nichol, also known as the Riddler.
So Edward in threatening riddles scrawled on the asylum
walls one would have to be severely paranoid to read threats
What is it that walks on four legs then two legs and finally
three legs?
A human being old man.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, human.
Yeah Oh, yeah, I'm so fucking smart Good try but the answer
to all three is a baby
What the fuck
that's horrible how can you even joke about that easily
doctor it's not my baby whoa geez really I sucked up that's
fucked up all right let's see what am I supposed to go oh
I'm so close to leveling up dad I I mean, if you think about
it, it works with old elderly, too.
Oh, there's...
Oh, I can't...
I don't have to upgrade yet, right?
Oh, no, that's just a gargoyle.
It's the simple things.
Oh, shit.
Look at his packs, though.
From that angle.
Alright.
Where am I supposed to go?
Locate and rescue Dr. Young.
Locate and rescue Dr. Kellerman.
Locate and rescue...
Dr. Chen.
Oh, it's Chen.
It's all the doctors.
Alright.
Does it really matter, though?
Do we really need to rescue all these doctors?
2 is enough.
Wouldn't 2 be enough, guys?
I'm so confused where to go.
Yeah, I don't like... The only thing I don't like is when
you go from detective mode... Oh, shit.
Nice.
When you go from detective mode, to like uh to like normal
mode i do not like the flashes i can literally just hire
more doctors outside of oh nice outside of gotham city i
know earlier i was like think of the doctors but now i'm
like wait i can hire more all right what do i upgrade
backseaters it's time it's time to optimize my build it's
time it's optimization armor okay version one all right holy
fuck oh my god the fucking icon for that why would they
money it's always money why you pay enough money people will
risk everything.
Where the fuck is the elevator?
Okay.
Wait, how do I open that door?
Can I open doors?
Oh, I just pressed...
How did I open...
God, I'm so...
How do I open this door?
Alright.
Wait, how do we save this game?
Where's the checkpoint?
Oh my god, where's the checkpoint in this game?
work of our new head of research, Dr. Panamika.
Since joining our team two years ago, Arkham is now at the
forefront of research into understanding the human mind.
Good afternoon, Arkham.
Let's talk about the mind.
How can such a complex entity be understood and eventually
treated when it breaks?
How, indeed?
Project Titan's goal is to create a test bed to fully probe
our special cases in a safe, risk-free manner.
Our goal is to cure the more unfortunate specimens, the
weak, those not physically up to the challenge that our
medical practices present.
Project Titan will make us a world-class facility, an
award-winning facility.
When you or someone you know is seriously distressed, there
are few institutions where they can be taken and where you
can be reassured that they are safe and undergoing the
finest care available.
packages can be found at the front desk.
Is that a real site?
I had to be like 14 years ago.
Slash prices.
We accept most major HMOs.
Let me introduce you all to the sterling work of our new
head of research.
Wait, let me open this door.
Is there no, I'll say when I open this door?
Let's try.
Does it tell me an icon?
Is that an icon?
How do I know?
How do I...
How do I know if that auto's saved?
me me me
okay did that auto save it saved all right all right we're
gonna call it here because in an hour we're gonna have
another stream I'm sorry if I couldn't do a longer stream
today it was a bonus this is a bonus stream but I had so
much fun um I'm gonna call it here so I can have a little
bit of time in between streams guys but thank you everybody
for coming i had so much fun this has been so fun so far uh
but thank you everybody thank you for all the super chats
for all the memberships i'll see you guys in an hour with
ditto and uto um we're gonna be playing apex rink uh
together we are the apex pred girl squad um um even though
uto is not pred she is pred in my heart always everybody
stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get
that blood flowing if you stay up for me maybe stay up a
little longer for some more for some apex yeah i'll see you
guys next time everybody bye guys